G1
eu fui boa tarde a todas as chame
Catarina Martins e sou muitas coisas
entre elas são três coisas podem
considerar e no tas sou feminista uma
acabaram de ver
sou a na política e eu sou a professora
de humanidades Sou professora de
Literatura e cultura na Faculdade de
Letras
e é uma função é nesta que eu vou sentar
a minha comunicação a Porque foi assim o
desafio que me foi proposto e começo por
dizer que é uma função difícil uma
função difícil porque parece que nós que
tratamos a literatura EA cultura somos
parasitas por nos alimentamos da arte
aquela arte que foi aqui tão falada em
muito bem
bom e porque se já para arte parece-me
ouvir valor de mercado e por isso é
desperdício de recursos o que será para
nós que da arte somos parasitas e da
arte nos alimentamos
ah ah eu acredito porém que preste as
minhas três funções ser feminista ser
política e ser profissional da cultura
Há uma razão muito forte que é pensar a
sociedade e que uma sociedade que não se
conhecem não se pensa a si própria não
será uma sociedade justa uma sociedade
digna e uma sociedade livre vou tentar
justificar aqui este meu ponto de vista
a primeira dificuldade que nós temos
Vamos estudos da cultura é saber o que é
que é cultura e olhando para isto a
nossa confusão penso que fica muito
clara a Camões Os Lusíadas não descola
com qualquer dificuldade a cultura ali o
patrimônio arquitetônico da Universidade
de Coimbra também mas se olharmos para
as capas dos Estudantes já muitos dirão
que não é cultura Eu talvez está
incluída as capas dos Estudantes não
serão a mesma cultura que esta cultura
popular que aqui vemos no folclore do
Minho O que é que estuda e a cultura
popular Quim Barreiros é cultura ou é a
antítese da cultura A Casa dos Segredos
Secret Story a cultura de massas é
cultura devemos estudá-la ou então
aquele grafite ou as obras de arte de
Joana de Vasconcelos Qual é a cultura
Qual é a contra-cultura alguma cultura
paga ou mais a mensagem do Papa
Francisco o trataríamos como cultura ou
como religião e olharemos para a
mensagem daquele chefe judaico como
cultural como religião cabe acabemos a
nós profissionais da cultura olhar por
exemplo a cultura que é feita em São
Carlos ou para a cultura que é feita num
circo para o pastel de nata como cultura
nacional que acontece vendo lá fora
enfrentassem ou perante cultura do
McDonald's para a nossa história como
cultura quando o livro de história e
depois quando é transportada para um
campo de futebol andamos nisto não
sabemos parece que as artes são o nosso
campo de trabalho mas aí a teremos outra
dificuldade o que é que a arte e o olho
para aqui
ou por exemplo para não falar demais
para este preste últimos Light em que
temos uma obra que está exposta no sítio
institucional o museu da UFC e temos um
quadro de Curvelo a origem do mundo e
temos uma artista que como veem foi
repetir o que o quadro fez no mesmo
local mas foi
censurada Por que já não se tratava de
arte amostra da mesma vagina e o que é
que ele é que ficamos nós profissionais
da cultura
ficamos como tudo isto não rejeitamos
Nenhuma destas manifestações de cultura
e vou explicar por que podemos para este
exemplo
em dezembro a pouco tempo que um amigo
que passava na no arco de almedina onde
todos já passaram e viram esta escultura
que os turistas olhavam para ela com
aquele menino que faz xixi nas ruas de
Bruxelas parece portanto que é o novo
ícone da identidade Coimbra
trata-se de uma escultura em bronze que
representa a canção de Coimbra a
guitarra de Coimbra e que têm formas
estilizadas de mulher Como podem ver que
era parte da frente quer da parte de
trás bom
acontece que no mês de julho do qual é
datado esta notícia retirada do Jornal
Local é este este monumento foi objeto
de um ato de vandalismo E rezava assim a
notícia baixa de Coimbra sofre
vandalismo contra a cultura o que é que
aconteceu aconteceu que alguém foi A
escultura pô a vaquinha e acho que
também o sutiã os ornamentos em papel
higiênico um ramo de flores e escreveu
na parede abaixo a cultura do machismo
imediatamente vieram funcionários
camarários trataram de limpar habita
escultura hábito ver nalismo e repor a
cultura tanto parece que os poderes
autárquicos poderes institucionais de
Coimbra sabe muito bem o que é cultura e
o que é vandalismo eu que estudo a
cultura e os meus colegas e as minhas
colegas não sabemos nada do que andamos
a fazer porque nós
ignorantes que somos estudar íamos o
monumento este daríamos o palato de
vandalismo ambos como Cultura Ah e por
quê Porque Ambos são cultura porque
ambos trabalham com palavras ambos
significam ambos os falam sobre a
realidade em que vivemos sobre as
dinâmicas que estão presentes na
identidades e as localizações de que
falam os indivíduos e as vidas que que
os produziram e mais sobre as relações
de poder que estão por trás dessas
manifestações
Isto é nós nos estudos da cultura
procuramos criar o espaço entre estas
manifestações que nós muitas vezes lemos
a superfície e aprofundá-las para tornar
claro como é que elas significam e o que
está por trás dela eu enquanto
estudiosos a da cultura olho para A
escultura e o que é que eu vejo vejo o
corpo erotizado do de uma mulher que vai
ser tocado pelo homem o homem que tem
direito a cantar o Fado de Coimbra que
começar bem é interdita a mulher e vejo
aqui uma relação de poder patriarcal
vejo aqui uma tradição elitista e
machista que é propagada de uma forma
conservadora e passar desista como a
tradição de Coimbra
quando se canta Coimbra é uma lição 1 o
livro é uma mulher só passa Quem souber
dirão os estudos da cultura não é um
belo elogio poético não é poesia que se
faz nem a Coimbra nem a mulher de
Coimbra nem a universidade é um discurso
de entrega Coimbra EA Universidade ao
poder masculino repara que reparem que a
mulher é musa o único que estuda que lê
que escreve que canta frente Essa musa
silenciosa que não têm voz é um homem é
o homem que passa Se souber quem souber
mas estamos culturais sem tirar partido
iriam a tal manifestação do vandalismo e
variam palavras também e criarem um
espaço entre aqueles que para elas olham
essas palavras e aqueles para elas Olha
reconheceríamos também aqui uma
manifestação de Cultura porque este este
tem estudo conjunto de palavras que nos
traz o vandalismo com as palavras que
são sutiã cuequinha o papel higiênico as
flores essas palavras e cruzam-se com o
texto que é a guitarra e reescrevem
reescreve a identidade de Coimbra
abrindo na identidade na tradição de
Coimbra um lugar para a mulher e tem
sido sempre secundarizado
invisibilizado silenciado e é para
partir daqui que nós podemos olhar para
as palavras e ressignificá-las sair do
dicionário que nos comprime e criar
outro dicionário o dicionário que vai
resgatar da invisibilidade as mulheres
poderosas que vivem que viveram nesta
cidade e que a história colocou apenas
num pedestal para ser Encantadas ou para
serem amadas como se diz Foi Inês de
Castro reparem como é machista toda a
nossa mitologia
tentou estudos culturais enquanto
eleitores destas dinâmicas sociais
destas tensões sociais damos de
instrumentos para recriar os dicionários
recriar as palavras e depois permite-nos
fazer escolhas escolher o que somos
escolher como nos comportamos escolher
como nós próprios nos inscrevemos e como
com que para e fazemos escolher como os
damos a ler a quem nos olha os estudos
da cultura dizem-nos sobretudo E aí vai
a minha parte política que a cultura
nunca é inofensiva que a cultura traz as
Tais relações de poder que eu falei e
que essas relações de poder essas
ideologias podem ser relações de
marginalização e de exclusão de opressão
tal como por exemplo quando olhamos para
este mapa este mapa está afixado em
todas as salas de aula de todas as
escolas do país numa ação promovida pela
presidência da república e pelo
Ministério da Agricultura das peças não
sei bem como é que se chama
Esse é o estudos da cultura de um
revelar as palavras que estão escondidas
por detrás deste mapa e que são as
palavras que ao longo da história
formaram a mitologia o dicionário o
dicionário o professor que nos oprime da
identidade nacional a par em Portugal e
mouse amar vimos ali no sei se consigo
apontar um Portugal minúsculo e marca
nunca mais Acaba a pequena nação que fez
a grande aventura dos descobrimentos que
usou dar mundos ao mundo que usou fazer
o que nunca ninguém fez que tem uma
miríade de heróis que realmente
transcenderam a dimensão humana estou a
falar dos descobrimentos como é evidente
hora os estudos culturais
preencheram o espaço entre estas
palavras EA ideologia o que este
discurso bebe e que esta discurso
reproduz e chamariam discurso
imperialista e discurso colonialista
os setores culturais revelaram a que
aqui está uma identidade e uma memória
coletiva que bebe nos mitos destacados
pelo Estado novo pelo período da
ditadura
falar no mar dizer que Portugal é mar
não é poesia não é um azul e no fensivo
é falar é fazer Renascer o Portugal que
subjugou povos que escravizou povos que
levou o seu direito à autodeterminação
numa aventura sem rumo que culminou na
guerra Colonial
felizmente tivemos o 25 de Abril para
pôr fim à ela os estudos culturais ligue
o espaço entre nós e estas palavras e
interpela nos perguntamos é esta a
identidade que queremos é com esse dente
nós podemos relacionar os no mundo com
outros povos e Sobretudo com os povos do
mundo a que se chamou lusófono e reparem
o abismo que está dentro desta palavra
lusófono não é neutra não é nada neutra
Esta palavra lusófono Afinal o espaço
entre é aquele que os estudos culturais
fazem para criar fraturas no olhar
rotinado o olhar rotinado perante o
mundo que nos rodeia todo ele significa
tudo ele é palavras e o nosso olhar está
domesticado para o ler determinadas
formas os estudos culturais provocam o
efeito de estranhamento aquele que
falava Freud na psicanálise aquele que
fala o resto para o teatro e o sou um
olhar de múltiplas perspectivas como
defende Unidos para a filosofia é
preciso cruzar perspectivas para que os
sentidos se tornem claros para que se
mostra o que há de poder a operação nas
palavras e o que é que elas podem trazer
de resistência de emancipação de
libertação
perante este mapa que nos traz a
ideologia dos descobrimentos podemos
colocar este olhar outro e já não não
falaríamos em descobrimentos Esta
palavra seria apagada do nosso
vocabulário o nosso dicionário seria
completamente outro é quando eu cheguei
aqui repararam que eu disse boa tarde a
todas certamente que muitos se
estremeceram e se sentiram
desconfortáveis com esta forma de
saudação porque dizer boa tarde a todos
é oprimir é silenciar é por de parte
mais de metade da população do planeta a
linguagem traz consigo esta ideologia os
estudos culturais servem para isso a
Rigor Eu deveria ter dito Boa tarde a
todas Olá a todos assim ser igualitária
mas no que não de mim ninguém disse isso
portanto eu fiz exatamente o contrário O
que fazem os estudos culturais
exatamente permitir que as palavras
ganham novos significados
por por novos mundos possíveis temos que
trabalhar com estrutura o pensamento Que
estrutura o pensamento são as palavras
portanto os estudos culturais fazem
aquilo que eu disse no início tentar
tornar a sociedade mais justa mais igual
aumentar a dignidade humana compreender
a cultura e alargar o espaço de escolhas
e alargar o espaço de adesão ou de
resistência é uma determinada ordem
social a um determinado poder é alargar
o espaço da emancipação individual e
alargar o espaço de liberdade Talvez o
que eu faço a não seja Afinal tão inútil
tá obrigada
E aí